it's good to see you i
talked a lot here about how difficult
2020 and 2021 have been for everybody
all walks of life uh you shared on
instagram your thoughts and sort of
where your head was at
as you were going into the new year i
thought that was a very cool thing to do
for the people
following you where would you say you're
at now like where's your head at
as we're going into the spring of 2021
um i think it's
it's feeling pretty hopeful you know um
it feels uh
feels like we may be back out on the
road at some point this year
uh you know maybe uh not in the capacity
that we were but
i think we'll have some shows which we
desperately all want
um so that feels good and then we have
some new music
you know that's that's almost ready to
put out so um
excited to to do that it's just it's
just uh the forward motion that we've
been missing
you know it's it's hard to sit still and
sit on your hands so
we have some things that are coming and
that makes us feel pretty good about it
yeah is there a bit of a tug of war for
you between the idea of wanting to get
back out there and just and but do your
job
and be out there entertaining people but
also the idea
of being able to actually have spent
some time at home
like is there a tug of war or are you
like ready to go uh no there's
definitely a tug of war there's always
been that tug of war and it's usually
been on the other side of things you
know because we've always been
gone and the tug was to go home and
now we've we've flipped the script a
little bit so
uh it's it's always a balancing act and
this one is now that it's flipped it's a
little bit harder to wrap our heads
around but
yeah it's a little strange to imagine
going back to what it was
you know um it'll look different for
sure but
we'll see you probably see my i have
daughters so i have pain
i noticed i noticed a bit off the top i
was like that's a good look
good luck you should little little
snowed in boredom
i ended up getting my nails painted but
yeah you got to keep that when you get
back on the road yeah right yes it might
be part of the look
have you kind of rediscovered anything
about yourself in the time that you've
spent at home with your family
um yeah sure i think you know there's a
lot of
um you know time for
being a little introspective and
retrospective and
you know just kind of um realizing
what about our careers in
general that we were taking for granted
that i was taking for granted i think
and um you know i think i've
i think i've learned relearned how to be
a father
maybe as evidenced
yeah yeah yeah it's out of how to be you
know more present
and and i've definitely learned you know
about myself that i need
i need some alone time as well i need a
little bit of solitude just to kind of
you know collect my thoughts and and be
better for my family
right you know i i'm wondering what
you know career-wise um you
you said that you sort of took for
granted i've talked to some people and
they said that
the rush of everything is something they
got caught up in and and though they
love it
they might have lost touch with a
certain side of themself or a certain
side of
what got them to where they are in the
first place yeah
i think that's just it is it's always
just go go go for so you get you get
swept up in those wheels
and you forget you know
you forget how much music meant to you
uh when you first started and now that
that
is sort of taken away from us a little
bit the live aspect of it anyway
and how therapeutic that is uh
you realize how much that means to your
life
so i think when we go back out there
it's going to be an emotional experience
you know for a while to go on stage
and and feel that energy again it's it's
almost like we've forgotten
what that energy feels like yeah well as
far as visibility goes
like for your band you guys had a good
year last year you took home a ton of
hardware
yeah i must you know it must have felt
pretty good where's who's keeping what
they're actually nice to us and they eat
they give us our own
everybody gets their phones
[Laughter]
the only one that they didn't uh is we
won this waffle house award
for um for like the most i think
i can't remember what the name of the
award was but
basically we were the highest played
song by
waffle house employees on their jukebox
so um
they gave us they gave us an award for
that and but they only gave us one so
jeff actually has that at his house
do you also get lifetime pass like
lifetime free waffle house yeah i know i
wish
[Laughter]
well the next big one up is the grammy
awards you're you're nominated for two
that must feel pretty cool
that feels amazing absolutely it's been
like you said it's been a really big
year for us and
kind of odd that we haven't been able to
quite celebrate it like
you normally would but um that was a
that was a real surprise to get those
nominations it was
so it came right at the right moment man
we needed we needed that little
boost of confidence yeah are you are you
guys the type to be like
okay we gotta prep let's write something
like let's write an acceptance speech or
is it just gonna be one of those things
where if it happens in the moment you're
gonna go with it
no we typically don't write them you
know it feels
i'm never really good with that kind of
thing i'd rather just get up and
you know for better or worse speak
what's on my heart
yeah now it's been a few years since
your debut album it's
like six years now i don't know if that
feels like a long time to you or if that
feels like it was just yesterday
it feels like both you know there's
times there's times when i look
back and it feels like ages ago that we
were just doing this and then it also
feels like a blink of an eye especially
when you're looking
at it through the lens of of this
pandemic and how it feels like things
are
you know how quickly it can be taken
away from you
and it really you realize that you know
five six years is
in the scope of what we plan to do with
our career is is very small
from year so to speak year zero to year
one
like you get this huge spike in just
fame
people just knowing who you are people
wanting things from you
is everything that you heard about being
famous
true like is it could you expect
everything that came to you
i mean it was different for all of us i
think for me personally
it was difficult because as silly as
this sounds
i never thought about being a famous
person
i thought about i thought about the
music being famous
and and sure i dreamt about
being on a stage with thousands of
people
but i didn't really i wasn't prepared
for
people to care about my daily life
and or my family life for
where i lived you know like those things
were things i didn't ever think about
and so it took me some time to wrap my
head around it for sure
yeah i mean in a scenario like this
where you're doing
a ton of interviews is it now something
that you are
you feel like it's kind of par for the
course or do you still get a bit of
i don't know like is there still a bit
of separation when people are talking
about you know your daughters your
family that sort of thing
right um you know now it's pretty good
it's normal
i've learned you know i have learned
that
interviews and things are a sign that
it's working which is good so i you know
never have a problem talking to anyone
because
that means they want to hear about our
music so
that's again it's a good thing
what keeps you guys like what what makes
you know that you guys are going to be
good for a long time
um you know i think just the fact that
that we love doing it this is something
that we would be doing anyway that we
were doing anyway
before we had success we were for many
many years a band
that never really thought we were going
to be
successful at the level that we are we
were just enjoying
playing music together and writing music
together and
we were being friends we were friends
long before we were banned so
i think as long as we can maintain that
friendship
and that love of music then
i think we're good how's the new stuff
sounding like how's it compared to the
stuff that we already know
uh it's a kind of uh a conglomerate of
everything that we've done i think
there's some stuff that kind of
uh would remind you of the first album
and some stuff that
sounds like the next natural progression
that we've taken
um you know we actually went into the
studio
in asheville north carolina right sort
of beginning of
fall and um we hunkered down for like
three weeks and we wrote and recorded
everything
on this new project right there and then
there so we didn't
you know pre-write any songs we just
went in wrote them and recorded them so
it's a cool little snapshot
of where we are as a band um
it's very cool to be able to say that
you know we talk about the hardware you
guys got a chance to take home
being nominated having sort of not about
the trappings but being like
where you are in your career but when
you look back on what you were doing
like the day before you got
signed is there a job that you had
you're so glad you don't ever have to do
again
yes uh when i first moved here
the first job that um would take me
was working for a moving company
and so i just uh i would show up every
day and
i always tell people imagine how much it
sucks to move
and now imagine doing it three times a
day
[Laughter]
yeah yeah that's the worst
so given everything that you've learned
in
six years which is can be a long time in
a short time depending on how you look
at it
what piece of advice would you go back
and give yourself
uh i think i would probably tell myself
um
to breathe a little bit and to um
and also to own it a little bit more i
think we probably
we were so um
sure that we weren't going to make it
that you know anything good that came
our way
in the beginning we would shrug off and
as a
as a you know mode of self-preservation
i think right instead of bringing it in
and accepting
the compliments and the awards and the
successes
it took us a while to to do that and so
i would say
from the get-go enjoy those successes
it's kind of a funny piece of advice to
hear but celebrating your
self can be kind of tough sometimes
right yeah
just yeah allow yourself to be proud of
yourself
right on man thank you so much for this
time great talking to you you're good
you got to keep the nails too
yeah on the road for sure
[Laughter]
thanks
you